hi i'm here in kaiapoi
behind me is the kaiapoi river
i'd like to talk to you about the
government's three waters reform
you'll have seen that there's been a lot
of material starting to be out in the
media and even in our local
newspapers we have been putting some
articles as a council there to explain
the position
i'm disappointed with the government's
advertising campaign
it presents a very misleading position
that we have sludge coming out of our
shower taps that is not correct
and it's inappropriate that that's how
this campaign is being uh put together
we're proud of what we've done as a
council
over the last 20 years we've invested
over 100 million dollars
making sure that you have safe
drinking water and also that we're
dealing with things responsibly like our
sewage
and our storm water
this coming week the council uh going
out to you with a
a letter and a pamphlet and a feedback
form
we want to know what your thoughts are
on the three waters reform
because at the end of the day you own
the assets and it's important for us to
know what your position is on it
our council is required by the
government to come back with a position
by the end of september
we're asking that you get your
information your feedback to us
following receiving the information by
the 5th of september we're going to hold
seven drop-in sessions that the
councillors
and myself will be attending and we
welcome your attendance you can also
give us your feedback on
waimakariri.govt.nz let's talk we'll be
in touch if there's any questions you
have
to us it's really important that we
receive your feedback before we make our
decision known to the government by the
end of september so please let us know
what you're thinking
thank you and we look forward to
receiving your feedback